[Music]
in but why no one submitted by Joe play
me a song Starbucks has apologized after
an incident involving two men being
arrested for nothing I saw this [ __ ] I
saw it too I didn't see it it's these
two black eyes waiting for their white
friend to show up right and they were
the manager called the cops
Oh manager yeah because waiting there
yeah I thought no loitering or did you
say something no I something shut the
[ __ ] up Bobby my God if there was any
place to get away with just sitting and
doing nothing like I'm not a whole life
is about but oh he farted
you made him fire on you act like that I
fart when you get confrontational like
that I fart don't anymore don't upset oh
yeah why are you taking the opposing
side here when you know that's not how
you feel that's true of all places
Starbucks is one where you can just
loiter exactly like how many times have
I brought my computer there I've been
broke as [ __ ] in college and just done
you know my homework there yeah I never
call the cops on yeah they're acting
like these guys came into the store
started playing dice and [ __ ] so we've
guys these two guys is there a video
there is a video of them getting
arrested yeah
initially they went in and they asked to
use a restroom the employee said no so
then they sat down and started just like
on their phones or just talking to each
other and apparently they were waiting
for their friend
the store manager asked him to leave and
they were like why like we're not doing
anything and that's when they called the
cops and then the cops arrived and
arrested the booth guys and there was
this witness there named Melissa she
tweeted this out said at Starbucks the
police were called because these men
hadn't ordered anything they were
waiting for a friend to show up who did
as they were taken out and handcuffs for
doing nothing
the other white people are wondering why
it's never happened to us when we do the
same thing so shares the video I watched
this what did they do one white guy
though he was like what did they do what
do they do he was trying to protect them
and I love it when why people get that
way cuz we need that help yeah we do
need that that's very true yeah
but that those were his friends and he
was it was a business meeting yeah
they're real estate guys yeah they were
meeting therefore to discuss real estate
and that's the guy who showed that was
their friend who was like what the [ __ ]
are they getting arrested for yeah yeah
Brandon Melissa followed that sweet up
with ever since I posted this I've had
white strangers and friends say there
must be something more to this story
that assumption is a big part of the
problem it does happen all the time just
not to you and me believe it and speak
up but whenever I go to Starbucks I buy
something it's not had nothing to do
with ID what what they did to these two
guys was wrong what I'm saying is that I
just you know when I go to a store buy I
agree though like if I'm gonna use a
store services I still I just buy
something just because I out of respect
to the Biscay but what if there was the
intention to buy but they were just
waiting for the friends who arrived I
know that's fine I'm not saying they did
it yeah I would say what's weird to me
is that I walk into a store I'm sitting
down and no one even notices me but then
these black guys get noticed
exactly it's like what the [ __ ] cuz I've
done that a million times where I would
just go to Starbucks and [ __ ] chill
for a minute now I'm feeling thirsty
I'll get up in an hour and I'll go buy
some [ __ ] nobody look at your eyes and
they go he's [ __ ] oh maybe that's
why he's a [ __ ] boy doesn't know
where he is
even don't even bother homeless people
homeless people are [ __ ] chilling
they're doing nothing they don't even
bother them how come they gotta bother
these two regular guys who just walked
up there at least there's two crack
dealers here [ __ ] tryna sell crack
that
exactly what they're doing right now
it's a shame the [ __ ] managers like
there's two guys [ __ ] trying to sell
a bunch of crack and heroin come here
and get them when these guys are puffing
me can weigh more money than anyone
working out that's exactly I think the
police are to blame though cuz if they
show up and they assess the situation
and they're not doing anything they
don't have to arrest me usually because
my brother-in-law he's a cop there are
many times when people have called for
things that are just so petty yeah you
know just like a white person be like
there's a black man I don't recognize
standing out you know on my drive you
know whatever not driveway but oh like
that's pretty scary that happens a lot
unlike you know the app next door all
the complaints if you look if you read
them closely they're always there's a
there's a black man standing here and I
don't recognize him there's so much of
them was just like the UPS delivery man
my brother-in-law he goes he shows up to
these things and he's like I'm not gonna
do anything I'm not gonna arrest them
yeah silly you called me for this
[ __ ] yeah there's a white lady up
north at a Starbucks and remember she
was because people were speaking Korean
she started going do you speak American
you heard a man you're an America and
she was out you know acting crazy in
that way how come she's not arrested for
being racist yeah yeah that should be
arrested right how come that never
happens when I'm around you and I we go
crazy that's I would get that angry that
should enrages me when white people tell
us yeah we you know have to speak
English yeah okay that's a very specific
white person too though that took a very
small sliver of like American white it's
kind of the yeah they're little that
really cool yeah because even white
people reject those kind of way yeah
yeah yeah when those white people like
do something all the other white people
are like oh my god no not again you know
it's so funny because all my life
I've swallowed things like that you know
no I didn't say calm yeah I just saved
the whole frame all my life I've
swallowed things like that babe okay no
better yeah like when I was up I was
working construction high school or
college I'm a man were you like sweeping
it was the guy that picked up the nut
symbol did you run for coffee
no I was a runner Oh so anyway there was
two runners me and this white guy and I
would go to some certain lumber yards to
oral wood
oh you really think you were playing off
my job but it's real life is real life
okay and this other white dude would go
to a different lumberyard and places to
go but one day he was sick so I had to
do all interrupt his runs as well so I
went to this one lumberyard and the guy
comes out and I said I work I work for
the Foxes right and he goes oh where is
that American looking fella he said
American looking because he was white
yeah and out back then I went oh he's
sick I didn't defend you know now I'd be
like what do you mean American looking
good yeah yeah yeah what is that
supposed to be you're talking to the
dirt of white people you're not even
talking to like normal white people
you're interacting with like white trash
yeah yeah but still stand your ground
but you should still stand your ground
and go what the [ __ ] does that mean
would you or no I would just be in the
past I would but then now I'm like this
is a [ __ ] idiot like I wouldn't take
a crackhead serious you know it's like
this guy is white trash he probably did
it past the third grade like why do I
need respect from this loser
I don't need respect from him yeah you
know I'd be offended if an intelligent
person would act the act [ __ ]
unintelligent that's what I'm like oh I
got a correct you [ __ ] I'm gonna
correct you right now
I'm gonna correct you right now when
idea that the third here'll and cruel
horror movie okay John Chow is my friend
John show when you were like the banker
or something right yeah whatever man
well you're in the food that was a suit
yeah yeah yes but John Joe wanted to use
my bathroom cuz his trailer was on the
other side of the thing right yeah and
so he was in my trailer
oh yeah I don't trailer yeah that's
[ __ ] sick I'm in the mob I'm in the
movie Hannah I don't think we're gonna
have trailers our movie I know I'm not
gonna do it then oh [ __ ] okay so so
check this out then I would I felt sick
so I had called for the medic so the
medic comes with his kit
he doesn't know John's in my trailer and
he goes Oh Stewie he doesn't he's a
white guy he does the accent is it good
no no but he's just going he'll your
medicine yeah you trying to be funny and
I whenever like a white dude does an
Asian accent I was laugh it off because
I don't want confrontation yeah John
walks out and he looks at him he goes if
you ever do that again you're fired
oh damn that's racist and then I
explained then we talk after you left is
it if you don't stop that in its tracks
now they're gonna do it to some poor
other Asian guy and they're gonna keep
perpetuating and keep doing it we have
to correct these white people when they
do racist [ __ ] regardless if they're
ignorant or not well in the past see I
don't know how to confront people like I
don't know how to talk about it I would
just pop them in his face there we go
that's the solution no it's not a
solution it's not I don't know how to
have a conversation it's either I'm
gonna start [ __ ] pounding your face
oh that's reenacted let's reenact it
okay I'm working at Arby's okay okay
you're getting a Bruce beef sandwich
for five dollars that one what yeah yeah
that one yeah yeah okay so sorry can I
get a sandwich yeah what kind of
sandwich you own man I want the roast
beef five for five roast beef left level
right qin qiong the [ __ ] you say as a
ching chong all right I'm gonna talk to
manager I said there we go okay I got do
it that way all right I got to like that
that's how you do it okay
he's saying that there are certain
people that are impenetrable exactly
don't waste your energy - they just
don't have the aptitude you understand
what you're saying they don't they feel
like nothing you could confront them all
you want to build wall no I don't think
there's anything wrong because some
people you beat their ass and they're
gonna tell their friends this [ __ ]
change I'll kick my ass don't stink oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah like if somebody
came up to a bean dip yeah right they
called you bean dip what would you say
yeah we do but we earned I earn my right
like you could do whatever a Filipino
joke you want right oh yeah call them
I earned my right yeah she's a jungle
Asian yeah but you know what to [ __ ]
them
I feel like he can talk so much trash
about Filipinos and Filipino traumatized
I hope you know they're generally okay
with it like they don't like they're
kind of like Mexicans they're
happy-go-lucky where you can rag on them
all day all day and it just rolls off
their shoulders but if I say anything
about Koreans the hate emails like yet
you can't be putting Koreans in that bad
light like I can't give it back that's
cuz Korea number one girl you like I
remember I made one comment about kimchi
yeah I feel like if you get a big set of
kimchi in the fridge and you put ice
trays in that ice is gonna smell like
kimchi
it does it does that's a fact and you
got a bunch of Korean emails right
loosen up they gotta loosen up that's
enough yeah so after this whole thing
happened with these two black guys in
Philadelphia two days later there was a
similar incident there was similar
racial bias in LA where there was this
guy trying to use her bathroom they
wouldn't give him the code and unless he
bought something but then there was a
white dude in the bathroom that he came
out he asked him like hey did you buy
anything before you got in the bathroom
he's like no I didn't buy anything that
went viral so now the CEO ended up
meeting with those two black guys from
Philadelphia CEO of Starbucks
yeseo Starbucks met up with them and
like how to talk with them and so now
there
they've announced that on May 29th eight
thousand Starbucks will close for racial
bias training pretty tight
that's probably much cheaper than having
to settle oh hell yeah well I also want
an Asian one where when Asians go into
Starbucks they don't just ignore us -
yeah they need to treat us like other
minority like we're not invisible I want
to be feel I want to be felt like I'm a
threat like when I walk I want I'll log
them to call the police on me yeah
like they think I'm gonna rape someone
that title what the [ __ ] so you're
saying I got a rape more people on I
guess that's it I want to be treated
equally like when I walk into a
Starbucks I want people to call the
police I want the police to come up to
me and be like yo you gotta [ __ ] buy
something
[Music]